Legen Sie die Tüte flach auf den Boden.
Glauben Sie nicht,
dass Sie damit durchkommen.
Kassenbons gehören in den Restmüll.
Echt?
Die sind aus Thermopapier.
Das weiß doch jeder.
Komme ich jetzt in den Knast,
weil ich den Aludeckel an meinem Joghurtbecher manchmal dran lasse?
Umweltsau!
Oder soll ich vielleicht
mit einem Cuttermesser
das Sichtfenster aus jedem
Briefumschlag rausschneiden?
Also ich rühre immer eine 20-prozentige Lauge
an und weiche den Kleber auf.
Mit Wattestäbchen. Aus Holz natürlich.
Die kommen dann
auf meinen Kaffeesatz-Komposthaufen.
Danke für den Tipp, Bullseye Joe.
Nicht dafür.
Das ist komplett albern.
Ich gehe jetzt.
Menschen wie Sie denken,
nur weil Deutschland Recycling-Weltmeister ist,
tragen Sie keine Verantwortung.
Es geht um unseren Planeten, Herr Mertz.
Warum ist der Ihnen so egal?
Wir müssen alle unseren Beitrag leisten.
- Ganz genau!
Aber wenn gemischte Verpackungen
so ein Problem sind,
warum darf die Industrie
die dann überhaupt herstellen?
Chef, ich habe hier freie Schussbahn.
Standby. Ich wiederhole, bleiben Sie auf Standby.
Holen Sie die Psychologin.
Übernehmen Sie.
Der Mann ist offenbar völlig verwirrt.
Herr Mertz. Aurel.
Ich verstehe dich ja. Du bist kein Täter.
Du bist Opfer eines undurchsichtigen Entsorgungssystems.
Ja. Ich meine, wer soll denn da den fucking
Überblick behalten?
So schwer ist das ja nun wirklich nicht.
Du machst mich krank!
Wegen dir ersticken Vögel an Plastik!
Vogelmörder.
Der hat ja auch schon mal Glasscherben
in den Glascontainer geworfen.
Wo sollen sie denn sonst rein?
Sondermüll!
Sondermüll.
*Bullseye Joe weint*
Jetzt reicht's!
Ich weigere mich, in so einer Welt zu leben.
In einem System, das uns zwingt,
uns gegenseitig zu zerfleischen.
Was wir brauchen ...
Nein, was wir verdienen, ist ein Staat,
der Großkonzerne und Verpackungshersteller
in die Pflicht nimmt.
Ein Staat, der für uns und unseren Planeten einsteht
und nicht die gesamte Verantwortung
auf die Endkonsumierenden abwälzt.
Das ist Ihre letzte Chance.
Legen Sie das Buntglas auf den Boden.
Neeeiiiiiiin!
Und was machen wir mit der Leiche?
Naja, Handy in die Wertstoff-Tonne,
Uhr auch, aber vorher Batterien rausnehmen.
Kleidung in den Restmüll
und Körper in die Bio-Tonne.
Nee ... Warte mal, Restmüll!
Fleisch kommt in den Restmüll oder warte ...
wars ... waren es die Knochen?
Wie war das noch mal?